und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend alle Blicke auf den Rasen in
Katar aber es lohnt sich für einen
Moment die Aufmerksamkeit woanders
hinzurichten aus China erreichen uns
Bilder wie wir sie von dort seit
Jahrzehnten nicht mehr gesehen haben
zumindest nicht vom chinesischen
Festland
allein die Tatsache dass eine solche
Flut von Videos um die Welt geht ist
bemerkenswert offenbar kommt die
staatszensur mit dem Löschen nicht
hinterher Miriam Steimer berichtet aus
Peking
steht auf alle die keine Sklaven mehr
sein wollen auf den Straßen von Peking
singen sie heute Abend die chinesische
Nationalhymne sie protestieren gegen die
extremen corona-maßnahmen
wir wollen keine corona-tests wir wollen
Freiheit sie bringen Blumen und zünden
Kerzen an denn ein Auslöser für den
Protest ist ein Wohnungsbrand im
Nordwesten des Landes mindestens zehn
Menschen kamen dabei ums Leben das löste
einen Sturm der Entrüstung aus viele
glauben dass die Menschen wegen
corona-absperrungen nicht aus dem
brennenden Haus kam
Millionen im Land sitzen selbst im
Lockdown und fragen sich ob sie bei
einem Feuer oder Erdbeben rauskämmen
auch an der Pekinger Tinka Universität
einer der Eliteunis des Landes
versammeln sich die Studierenden wegen
der corona-regeln dürfen sie seit Wochen
den Campus nicht verlassen doch nicht
nur in der Hauptstadt auch in Wuhan oder
lanjoe trauen sie sich auf die Straße
hier trifft ihre Wut eine Teststation
hier den pingen tritt zurück das rufen
Sie in Shanghai denn während China jeden
Tag eine neue Rekordzahl an infizierten
meldet hält die Staatsführung weiter
stur an den extremen Maßnahmen fest die
Menschen wären sich die weißen Blätter
sie werden zum Symbol der Proteste würde
was draufstehen werden sie als
polizeibeweis noch gefährlicher es ist
schon so in China gefährlich genug zum
Protestieren auf die Straße zu gehen
wie viele inzwischen in Polizeigewahrsam
sind wissen wir nicht die Menschen
versuchen ihre Meinung zu sagen in einem
Land ohne Meinungsfreiheit
man kann nur hoffen dass die chinesische
Führung nicht tut was Diktaturen gerne
tun wenn es innenpolitische Probleme
gibt einen Krieg in der Nachbarschaft
anzetteln lenkt ab und diszipliniert das
Volk
Wladimir Putin hatte damit in der
Vergangenheit ja gute Erfahrungen
gemacht seine diversen kriege auch der
2014 gegen die Ukraine stärkten seine
Machtposition nach innen mit diesem
großkrieg jetzt hat er sich aber
verschätzt und auch das Kalkül die
Ukraine mit der Zerstörung ihrer
Infrastruktur niederzubringen geht
bislang nicht auf Henna Hebestreit ist
für uns in der Ukraine
auch wenn in ihren Portemonnaies das
Geld knapp ist immer noch besuchen viele
Menschen den Markt von Odessa wo sich
für einen Moment vergessen können das
Krieg ist das Angebot ist erstaunlich
groß aber für die Einheimischen Erzeuger
ist es auf die einzige Möglichkeit ihre
Produkte zu verkaufen denn alte
Lieferketten sind gestört trotzdem
warten viele hier vergeblich auf
Kundschaft
es ist sehr schwierig für die Leute
viele sind weggegangen andere kaufen nur
noch wenige 100 Gramm meines Käses die
haben nur noch Kleingeld
die Geldautomaten geben kein Bares
entweder weil die konnten längst leer
sind oder nach russischen Angriffen der
Strom ausfällt dann wird also nicht nur
das fehlende Licht zum Problem der
Großraum Kiew mit seinen einsmals drei
Millionen Menschen leidet ganz besonders
unter russlandsattacken auf die
kritische Infrastruktur Bürgermeister
Klitschko will auf einer Konferenz in
Brüssel um ausländische Hilfe werben für
den Wiederaufbau
wir denken sehr optimistisch und wir
haben Pläne statt wieder aufzubauen und
statt zu entwickeln und
deswegen wir sind bereit sehr viele
Projekte zu präsentieren an unsere
Partner und sehr dankbar an unsere
Partner für Unterstützung in den
Markthallen von Odessa gibt es ein
Produkt nach dem ganz viele Fragen
batteriebetriebene Lampen die auch dann
noch funktionieren wenn der Strom mal
wieder weg ist
und dann schauen wir nach nach Italien
nach den schweren Stürmen und Unwettern
der letzten Tage war es auf Ischia heute
wieder ruhig und sonnig so wie die Insel
bei Touristen beliebt ist auch
exkanzlerin Angela Merkel hat dort ja
immer wieder gerne Urlaube verbracht
im Norden der Insel bietet sich derzeit
jedoch ein Bild der Zerstörung und das
wird weiter verzweifelt nach Vermissten
gesucht mindestens fünf Menschen sind
durch die Schlammlawine ums Leben
gekommen
nur mühsam kommen Sie voran selbst mit
vereinter Muskelkraft versuchen Sie
Schutt und Geröll zu bewegen Feuerwehr
Rettungskräfte auf der Suche nach
Verschütteten dennoch immer werden
Menschen vermisst selbst im Meer tauchen
sie nach ihnen suchen ob die Menschen
mit ihren Autos oder durch die
geröllmaßen mit ins Meer gerissen wurden
Ischia die Urlaubsinsel im Golf von
Neapel nach den Tagen des Starkregens
und der Stürme ist wenigstens das Wetter
besser geworden lässt aber auch das
Ausmaß der Katastrophe deutlicher
erkennen heute wurden weitere Opfer
geborgen darunter auch ein Kind die Zahl
der Toten steigt auf fünf
vor allem der Küstenort Kaiser mit Joola
Terme wurde in der Nacht auf Samstag
schwer vom Unwetter getroffen innerhalb
kürzester Zeit stürzten Fluten und hänge
ins Tal Schlamm und Gestein trieben
durch die Straßen Autos und Busse
eingegraben in Match die Diskussion über
die Gründe hat in Italien längst schon
begonnen während hunderte Bewohner ihre
Häuser verlassen mussten für mich ist es
in diesem Moment wichtig Menschen zu
retten wir können die Ursachen
diskutieren aber nicht jetzt jetzt ist
die Zeit zum Handeln gerade auf der
beliebten Urlaubsinsel wurde viel gebaut
zu viel wie Anwohner sagen und in
steilhagen jetzt stehen diese am Abgrund
und weitere Nachrichten des Tages hat
jetzt Heinz Wolf
angesichts der anhaltenden russischen
Angriffe auf die Ukraine wird auch über
die Situation der geflüchteten in der EU
diskutiert der Vorsitzende der
Europäischen Volkspartei Manfred Weber
sagte der Bild am Sonntag wenn jetzt
über den Winter hinweg weitere Ukrainer
gezwungen werden zu fliehen müsse das
westliche Europa mehr Verantwortung
übernehmen EU in den Kommissarinnen Ilva
Johannsson sagte die Solidarität unter
den EU-Ländern sei intakt Sie dies auch
darauf hin dass Ukraine überall in der
EU den gleichen Zugang zu den
Sozialsystemen hätten
die beiden großen Kirchen in Deutschland
haben mit Gottesdiensten ihre
traditionellen Spendenaktionen zur
Weihnachtszeit begonnen beim
evangelischen Hilfswerk Brot für die
Welt steht die Kampagne in diesem Jahr
unter dem Motto eine Welt ein Klima eine
Zukunft beim katholischen Lateinamerika
Hilfswerk Adveniat unter dem Leitwort
gesund sein fördern
[Musik]
Nordkoreas Machthaber Kim Jong unwill
künftig über die stärkste Atomstreit
Macht der Welt verfügen laut der
staatlichen Nachrichtenagentur gab er
dieses Ziel nach dem Test einer neuen
Interkontinentalrakete aus ihre
potenzielle Reichweite soll ausreichen
um US Festland treffen zu können
zwei Meldungen vom Wintersport Bob Pilot
Francesco Friedrich hat im kanadischen
Whistler nach seinem Sieg im Zweier
gestern heute auch im Vierer Bob
gewonnen und im alpinen Skiweltcup hat
in der Abfahrt Thomas Dresden ein
erfolgreiches Comeback gefeiert er fuhr
in Lake Louis mit nur einer Sekunde
Rückstand auf den 8 Platz gewonnen hat
Alexander Armut Grill der aus Norwegen
und noch kurz die Wetteraussichten
morgen gibt es im Nordosten etwas Sonne
sonst ist es trüb im Westen regnet es
leicht die Temperatur steigt auf 3 bis
11 Grad auch in den nächsten Tagen gibt
es viele Wolken es regnet aber nicht
viel dafür wird es kühler am Donnerstag
nur ein bis sieben Grad
so damit gehen wir jetzt ganz schnell ab
in unser WM Studio damit noch Zeit ist
für eine kurze Analyse dessen was man
der ersten Halbzeit zu sehen bekam das
bleibt spannend auf Wiedersehen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]